it's more just red and blue like teams
they're arbitrary teams
yeah are they so how arbitrary are these
teams i guess is another completely
arbitrary
so yeah well you kind of imply that
there's i don't know if you're sort of
in post analyzing the patterns because
it seems like there's a network effects
of like you just pick the team red or
blue
and it might have to do with college you
might have to do all those things but
like
it it seems like it's more about
uh just the people around you correct
so less than whether you went to college
or not i mean it's almost like it seems
like
it's it's almost like uh weird like a
network affects a hard
there's certain strong patterns right
you're identifying
but i don't know it's sad to think that
it might be just
teams that have nothing to do with what
you actually believe
well it is slacks i look i mean i don't
want to believe that but the data points
me to this which
especially 2020. i'm one of the people
chief among them
i will own up to it here i was totally
wrong about why trump was elected in
2016.
i believed and based a lot of my public
commentary beliefs on this
trump was elected because of a rejection
of hillary clinton
neoliberalism on the back of a
pro-worker
message which was anti-immigration
it was its pillar but alongside of it
was a rejection
of free trade with china and
generally of the political correctness
and globalism
which has been come in through the
uniparty and
same thing here with the military
industrial complex and endless war
he rejected all of that wait what's
wrong with that prediction
i was wrong man and the reason i know
this is that
it sounds right i wish it i honestly
wish it was true
but here's the truth trump actually
governed largely
as a neo-liberal republican who was
meaner online
and who departed from orthodoxy in some
very important ways don't get me wrong i
will always
support the trade war with china i will
always support not expanding the wars in
afghanistan and in iraq
i will support him moving the overton
window on a million different things and
revealing once and for all that gop
voters don't care about
economic orthodoxy necessarily but
here's what they do care about
trump got more votes in 2020 than he did
in 2016
despite not delivering largely largely
for all the trump people out there
on that agenda he wasn't more pro-union
but he won more union votes
he wasn't necessarily more pro-worker
but he actually won more votes in ohio
than he did in 2016. and he won more
hispanic votes
than despite being you know all the
immigration agenda
rhetoric etc here's why it's about the
culture
which is that the culture war is so hot
that negative partisanship is at such
high levels
all of the vote is geared upon what the
other guy might do in office and there's
a poll actually just came out by echelon
insights
crystal and i were talking about it on
rising the number one concern
amongst democratic voters is trump
voters
number one concern not issues
like trump voters and number two is
white supremacy
and so like which is basically code for
trump voters
and it is the same for the other side
well so on the right the number one
concern
is illegal immigration um and number i
think
three or four or whatever is antifa
which is code four
on the right is the policy well well
yeah it's funny
i saw ben shapiro talking about this but
the reason why i would
functionally say it's the same is
because the i mean
you can believe whether it's a true or
not i think it actually largely is true
but like
did a lot of gop voters feel like a lot
of illegal immigration is code for
like people who are coming in who are
going to be legalized are going to go
vote democrat
like i can i can just explain it from
their point of view so like
what does that actually mean each other
like yeah
each other which is that the number one
concern is
the other person so negative
partisanship has never been higher
and i think people who had my thesis in
terms of why trump was
elected in 2016 you have to grapple with
this like how did he win
10 million more votes he came 44 000
votes away from winning the presidency
across three states
like i don't none of our popular
discourse reflects
that very stark reality and i think
so much of it is people really hate
liberals like they just really hate them
and i was driving through
rural nevada before the election and i
was like
literally in the middle of nowhere and
there was this massive sign this guy had
out
in front of his house and it just said
trump colon [ __ ]
your feelings and i was like that's it
that is why people voted for trump and i
don't want to denigrate it because
they truly feel they have no cultural
power in america
except to raise the middle finger to the
elite class
by pressing the button for trump i get
that that's actually a totally
rational way to vote it's not the way i
wish we did vote but like
you know that's not my place to say so
yeah this is interesting if you could
just psychoanalyze
i'm again i'm probably naive about this
but
i'm really bothered by the hatred of
liberals
it's uh it's a this amorphous monster
that's mocked it's like the shapiro
liberal tears and i'm also really
bothered by
uh probably more of my colleagues and
friends
the hatred of trump yeah uh
the the trump and and white supremacist
so apparently 70 there's 70 million
white supremacists
75 million sorry there's millions
of white supremacists and apparently
whatever liberal is i mean lib
you know literally liberal has become
equivalent to white supremacists in the
power of negativity it arouses
i don't even know what those i mean
honestly i just don't they've become
swears essentially
uh is that i mean how do we get
out of this because that uh that's why i
just don't even say anything about
politics online because it's like
really like you you can't
you if here's what happens anything you
say
that's like thoughtful like hmm i wonder
the
immigration something right i wonder
like why you know uh we have
these many we allow these many
immigrants in or the
some version of the like thinking
through these difficult policies and so
on
that they'll immediately try to find
like a single word in something you say
they can put you in a bin of liberal
or white supremacists and then hammer
you to death
by saying you're one of the two and then
everybody just piles on
happily that we finally nailed this
white supremacist
or liberal and that
is this some kind of weird like feature
of online communication that we've just
stumbled upon
is there a way or is it possible to
argue that this is like
a feature not a bug like this is a a
good thing
yeah well look i just think it's a
reflection of who we are people like to
blame social media i think we're just
incredibly divided right now i think
we've been divided like this
for the last 20 years
you